ايام معدوده مشاهدينا تفصل الولايات
المتحده عن كارثه اقتصاديه وشيكا وتبقى
عصا الاتزان بيد الكونجرس اقل من اسبوع
امام واشنطن لاتخاذ قرار حول رفع سقف
الدين الامريكي الانظار الان متجهه لقبه
الكابيتال اذ يجتمع مجلس النواب للنظر في
مشروع قانون الماليه والذي هيكله اتفاق
الرئيس بايدن وزعيم الجمهوريين كاظم
سقف الدين ليس نهايه الازمه حيث تمرير
القانون بالكونغرس يصطدم باعتراضات ابرزها
ان الاتفاق لا يصل الى الدرجه المطلوبه من
حد الانفاق الفيدرالي بالاضافه الى
الانتقادات بشان القيود الكبيره على
الانفاق والتي يحملها مشروع القانون ومع
ذلك ترى
في طريقهما للحصول على دعم كاف من الحزبين
لتعليق حد الدين في نهايه المطاف
تحدثت الى عدد من المشرعين ويبدو لي الوضع
جيدا وسننتظر التصويت
في الدين ينص على تعليق الالتزام بحد
الدين البالغ 31 تريليونان و400 مليار
دولار حتى يناير 2025 مقابل تخفيض بعض
جوانب الانفاق الفيدرالي
لتتمكن الحكومه الامريكيه من تسديد ديونها
والابقاء على مستوى الانفاق التقديري
وزيادته عام 2025 بنسبه واحد في المئه وهي
اموال يتم توجيهها الى الاسكان والتعليم
وغيرها من البرامج الفيدراليه
منح مجلس النواب 72 ساعه للاطلاع على
مشروع القانون قبل التصويت عليه
لكن الاتفاق لم يتضمن التخفيضات الكبيره
التي يريدها الجمهوريون
ومع ذلك مشاهدينا والرغم التصريحات
المتفائله الى ان تمرير القانون قد
يواجهوا عقبه اجرائيه قبل الخامس من يونيو
الجاري وهو الموعد الذي قد تفتقد فيه
الحكومه الامريكيه للاموال وتعجز عن دفع
مستحقات ديونها وفواتيرها ومعاشات التقاعد
ورواتب الموظفين الفيدراليين عمق هذه
الازمه هو عدم حسم الامر بعد بسبب معارضه
شديده سواء من الجمهوريين او الديمقراطيين
في مجلس النواب فالجمهوريون ينتقدون ما
وصفوه بتنازلات قدمها مكارتي اثناء
مفاوضاته الماريتونيه مع بايدن اما
الجمهوريون ينتقدون قيود الانفاق على
البرامج المحليه ومع ذلك يامل الجمهوريون
في مجلس النواب بتامين 150 صوتا لصالح
الاتفاق فيما ستحسم اصوات الديمقراطيين
الوسطيين المنافسه للوصول الى
عتبهمانيه عشر صوتا وهي اللازمه لتمرير
القانون لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات